NICOLAS GARNIER: --Google Drive
and have a bunch of
interests in OAuth2.
And also with us is Ali.
Ali, can you maybe
present yourself?
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ali.
I work on Google Drive Developer
Relations, also one
of the developers of the
OAuth Playground.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And Sergio?
What about you?
SERGIO GOMES: Hi.
I'm Sergio.
I work in the London office.
I work on the AdSense APIs.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So today we're
going to talk to you a
bit about OAuth2, describing to
you how it works, how you
can use it to authorize and use
the Google APIs and access
Google users' data basically.
So we'll go into a bit of
details on how the flows work
and how THE critical works
in a very mostly
practical point of view.
And after that, we'll actually
demonstrate how it works live
with some data using a really
cool tool called the OAuth2
Playground that you'll
see in a bit.
And I guess that's it
for the agenda.
So first, let's start.
So what is OAuth2, basically?
So OAuth2 is what we call
an authorization--
and authentication, actually--
protocol.
We use it to basically allow
third-party developers to
access users' data
on their behalf.
They're going to gain access
to the users' data, so for
example, to your Contacts data
or your Google Calendar data.
That's hosted on Google Cloud.
So to illustrate that, let me
first show you a real-life
example of how OAuth2 it works
out there, how people have
been using it to access
users' data.
So let me share my screen.
All right.
Share selected window.
Can you guys see my screen?
Sergio?
Ali?
Yep?
SERGIO GOMES: Yep.
ALI AFSHAR: Yep.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So this
is MindMeister.
MindMeister is one of the web
applications out there that
are using some Google APIs.
They are an application
to create mind maps.
They have this mind map editor,
which is really cool.
I invite you to try it out.
One other feature that
illustrates how OAuth2 works
is their sharing feature.
So once you've created a mind
map and you want to share it
with your buddies, or your
colleagues, or friends, you're
simply going to click share
here, and you're going to be
brought to these sharing
dialogue.
And if you don't want to type
the whole email address or you
don't remember the email
addresses of your friends and
colleagues, you have this
auto-complete button here.
What it's going to do, it's
going to ask for--
and that's OAuth2.
We're seeing OAuth2 in
action right now.
It's going to ask access to
your Google Contacts data.
So this is how OAuth2
works, basically.
You have to redirect the user
to this, what we call the
Grants page here, the Grants
screen, that asks the user if
he can let this application
manage their contacts here,
for example.
So let's say I can trust
MindMeister.
I'm going to allow them to
access my data here.
So how it works is we're
redirected back to
MindMeister.
And MindMeister got these tokens
we're going to see in a
bit more detail right after with
Sergio how that works.
But with this token, MindMeister
is going to be
allowed to fetch all of my
contacts because I've given
them the right to do so.
And here, as you can see, this
is all my friends and my
contacts that are the ones
you can see in Gmail.
And they started fetching the
list of all my contacts.
And then you can use these
contacts that were on Google
to share mind maps with
your friends.
Let me go back.
So that was it about how it
works in real life, the user
experience that you're
going to see.
And now we're going to
switch to Sergio.
Sergio is going to show you in
a bit more detail the flow,
how it works behind the scenes
basically, how the protocol
works behind the scenes.
And after that, we'll
see with some more--
live using the OAuth2
Playground, see
the protocol in action.
So Sergio, if you
could go ahead.
SERGIO GOMES: Sure.
All right, let me start by
sharing my screen as well.
I've got a little incognito
window set up with a couple of
things that I want
to show you.
All right, so to start off, I'm
going to give you just a
quick look at the diagram
for OAuth2.
And this looks really,
really complicated.
But as Nicolas showed you
earlier, the user experience
is actually relatively simple,
where you get a prompt asking
you to provide access to the
different scopes which are
being requested.
You authorize it, and somehow,
magically, the application
gets all of the data that it
needs, gets your credentials.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And Sergio,
sorry to disturb you, but if
that wasn't clear and if I
haven't stated very clearly,
the very, very big advantage
between this and what we used
to have in the past
is that the user
doesn't share their passwords.
So you don't share your username
and password with the
third-party application.
And the third-party application
only gets access
to the data that you've allowed,
so in the example
before, only the global
contacts data.
They don't have your password,
and they cannot go in Gmail
and change it.
They cannot get their passwords
stolen that could
happen with third-party
applications
or stuff like that.
So that's one of the
main advantages.
Sorry, Sergio.
SERGIO GOMES: That's
all right.
Exactly.
So all of the authentication
part is handled by Google.
So Google handles your
passwords, making sure you are
who you claim to be.
And then the only thing that you
need to provide with OAuth
is the authorization part.
So that's the part where you're
asking the user to give
you access to their data.
So that's where OAuth2
comes in.
And that's where this
diagram comes in.
So the first thing that happens
is that there is a
request sent to the server.
The user gets redirected to
the authentication page.
They perform their logging in,
so the authentication step
happens there.
And then the user gets
redirected back to your
application on a callback
URL that you specified.
And I'm going to show you how
to set up all of this from
scratch with a new project
on your APIs console.
So once your application gets an
exchange code that you can
use, this exchange code, you
then make a second request to
the server, and you exchange
this for tokens.
And you get a token response,
which includes
two different tokens.
One is a refresh token, and
one is an access token.
Now, the access token is the one
that you can actually use
to make requests.
But this token is short-lived.
It'll only exist for
a relatively
small amount of time.
That's where the refresh
token comes in.
This is a token that you can
store on your site, which is
specific to a user.
And it allows you to request new
access tokens as needed.
Now I'm going to show you how to
set up a new project using
the APIs console.
It's this address here in case
you haven't seen it.
Once you sign up to the page
for the first time, you get
this little prompt,
and you can create
your own little project.
And here you go.
It creates a new project
by default,
just called API Project.
And you get a list of all of the
different Google APIs that
are available.
You can enable it.
You get a little Terms
and Service.
And once you accept that, you
can then go into the API
access page for your project,
which by default doesn't have
any OAuth2 data.
It only has your simple API
access data, which only allows
you to make unauthenticated
requests.
So any API that requires you to
access protected user data
will not work without an
OAuth2 authentication.
So this is where come here.
You create a new client ID.
You just give your project a--
"sample" here.
And here is the important
part.
This is where you're choosing
your type of application.
Now, today, we're only going
to be talking about web
applications.
But there are also service
accounts in the installed
applications.
You could take a look at our
documentation later on to see
what the difference is with
these different types of
authentication.
But for both server side web
apps and client side web apps,
it's the web application that
you need to choose here.
And here you can set up your
site, your host name.
You can choose between HTTP
and HTTPS Of course, you
should always be using
HTTPS where possible.
You just input your site
name here, and you
create your client ID.
Now this will give you
a couple of things.
It'll give you a client ID,
which you are going to make a
part of your application, so
that it can identify you as a
developer, and the client secret
as well, although I
believe this is only used for
installed applications if I'm
not mistaken.
So that's it for creating
a project.
So how do you actually
use this?
So going back to the web flow
here, you're going to have to
make an initial redirect
to send the user to the
authentication page.
You're going to get
a code back.
You exchange this code
for the two tokens.
And then finally, you make an
API call with the tokens.
All right.
I think that's mostly it for
the web server flow.
So I'll hand it off to Ali now,
who should be able to--
oh, actually just before that,
I'd like to show you a quick
demo of the server side flow
using our client libraries.
We have client libraries for
many different programming
languages, one of them, PHP, and
that's the one we're going
to be showing you today.
There are samples already
included with the PHP client
library for the AdSense
Management API.
And that's actually what I'm
going to be showing you here.
So I've got this set up on my
local machine here, so I'm
going to be calling these
from local hosts.
This is actually the
wrong URL, sorry.
I'm going to be calling these
from local hosts.
But, of course, the experience
would be the same if you had
this set up somewhere online.
So I'm just going to
log into account.
And this is what you get.
This is the user experience when
you're authorizing your
application.
This is what the
user will see.
So they just--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Allow access?
Was that correct?
SERGIO GOMES: Yep.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Right here,
just talking a bit more detail
of this page, the kind
of parameters
you pass it, so that's--
the URL that you see up there,
that's where you passed what
we call a scope.
A scope defines basically each
of the APIs you want or the
kind of data you
want access to.
So here you've added you've
probably asked
for the AdSense scope.
You can have more than one.
So if you wanted to have access
to AdSense and Google
Contacts, in the URL you would
have added the scope for
AdSense and for Google Contacts
and for any other
APIs that you wanted
to have access to.
And so I just wanted
to mention that.
SERGIO GOMES: Exactly.
And to add on to what you're
saying, you should actually
request as many as possible
in the same request.
Because every single time that
you request access to a new
scope, you're going to have to
send the users through this
authorization flow again.
So you'll definitely want to
make sure that you request
access to all of the APIs you
need at the beginning, so that
the user only sees the
authorization flow once.
And this prompt here requests
access to all of the
applications in one
single step.
This will also help you later
on when you're saving your
credentials for later reuse so
that you don't have to send
the user through the flow every
single time they log in
to your website.
That's actually controlled by
this parameter here, which you
see me highlighting, access
type equals offline.
This means that your application
can request access
to the user's data even if the
user is offline and also
allows you to store this
data for later use.
NICOLAS GARNIER: That's
basically going to give you
the refresh token that
we talked about.
SERGIO GOMES: Exactly.
NICOLAS GARNIER: The refresh
token, which can be used in an
unlimited period of time,
unlike the access token.
If you didn't have this access
type equal offline, if you had
access type equal online, we
would only grant an access
token when you exchange
the code.
And you would only have access
to the users' data for one
hour, which is the current
validity and the usual
validity in Google APIs.
I mean, the usual time
to lift off access
tokens in Google APIs.
SERGIO GOMES: Exactly.
So here by clicking allow
access, it's a little bit too
fast so you couldn't really
see what happened.
But the user got redirected back
to the callback URL that
we set up in the Google
APIs console.
And this callback URL is the one
that handles the request.
Now, the callback URL
will get the code as
we mentioned earlier.
I'll show the flow here.
So this code, you then make a
second request to exchange for
the tokens.
And the tokens--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Just to be
clear, the second request is
done server side.
The user doesn't see anything.
So this doesn't affect
the user experience.
It's just exchanging the
code to get the tokens.
So we don't pass the tokens.
There's a simple technical
reason.
We don't pass directly the
access token and the refresh
token in the URL back to the
client on the server side flow
because we wanted to allow users
to be able to use HTTP
URLs, callback URLs.
And as you already know, HTTP
callback URLs could be
intercepted by a man in
the middle attack.
So the workaround we found
is it was too critical.
You send a code and then this
code is exchanged using your
client ID and client secrets
your OAuth2 credentials to get
the tokens back.
So that's basically
how it works.
SERGIO GOMES: Right.
So going back to our example
here, now that we are
authenticated, we can run a
number of requests on this.
Here, just for illustration
purposes, I'm just going to
get all of the ad clients
on this account.
And we're getting an error here,
of course, because this
is a live demo, and all live
demos have problems.
But here it looks like I
authenticated with the wrong
user that doesn't really have
an AdSense account.
So this is a response
from the API.
It's just not the response
we're looking for.
In any case--
NICOLAS GARNIER: It's
not a problem.
See, we'll see later on
the OAuth2 Playground.
We'll run a bunch of other demos
using other APIs that
should work for us--
SERGIO GOMES: Exactly.
NICOLAS GARNIER: --hopefully.
We cannot do worse now.
We failed all our demos,
our first ones.
So now we can only improve
from now on.
SERGIO GOMES: It can
only improve
from now, that's correct.
Right, so I just wanted to talk
a little bit more about
what you can do to prevent the
user from going through a lot
of authorization requests.
So as we were mentioning
earlier, if you set up your
access type as offline, it means
that you'll get back
both an access token in the
refresh and a refresh token.
Now, the access token is the
one you can use to make
requests immediately.
But it's important that you
save this refresh token.
This refresh token is per
user and per scope.
So it only works for
the scopes that
you initially requested.
Once you store it, this token
is valid indefinitely.
The only way that it can get
revoked is if the user logs
into their account settings
and revokes access to your
application.
And once you have this refreshed
token, then you can
use it to automatically, without
redirecting the user
anywhere, get new access tokens
to be able to access
the same data.
So it's important to note this,
because if you don't ask
for offline access and if you
don't star these refresh
tokens, you're going to be
prompting your users all the
time with authorization
requests, and they're going to
get very sick of your
application very soon.
All right, so things work a
little bit differently on the
JavaScripts side of things, so
your application is client
side rather than server side.
And Ali is going to be talking
to you a little
bit more about that.
Ali?
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks, Sergio.
So you just mentioned the really
interesting point about
the web server side flow.
It's in two steps, really.
The first step is between the
user and the OAuth service,
where the user says,
yes, I'm happy.
Yes, I am myself.
I've authenticated.
I'm happy to grant access.
The second step of it was an
exchange between the server
ie, the application and
the OAuth service.
And that exchange involves the
applications credentials.
So it's two steps-- one, the
user's credentials, the other
one is the application's
credentials.
And they all get together and
agree that this is a good
thing to happen.
Now, the difference in
JavaScript on the client in
the browser is that
nothing is secret.
So you know that you just can't
keep a secret in the
browser, because someone can
just look at the code.
And so instead of having
the two-step
process, we say, OK, fine.
We won't do that.
We'll have a single-step
process, where instead of
asking for a code, which you can
then exchange for a token,
you just ask for a token.
And that token comes back
in the form of a
fragment in the URL, OK.
So that just--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Sorry.
ALI AFSHAR: --prevents
it from being--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Can
I do it again?
It's important to note here
that fragments in the URL
cannot be intercepted by a
man-in-the-middle attack.
Only the browser sees it.
So the fragment parts are on the
browser side and don't go
through all the hops, all the
servers that redirects the
actual HTTP request.
So that's why it's actually
secure to give an access token
directly in the URL in
a hash fragment.
And that's the main difference
between the JavaScript flow
and the server.
ALI AFSHAR: It's exactly
right, Nicolas.
It's safe, and it only
takes one step.
Sergio, could you possibly
stop presenting?
Is that possible?
He's gone.
SERGIO GOMES: Am I
still presenting?
Sorry about that.
All right, there we go.
It should be good now.
ALI AFSHAR: You make a similar
kind of request.
You redirect the browser.
You again need to redirect
the URI.
The scopes are exactly
the same.
Another main difference in
when you're calling it is
there's no potential
to have offline.
You can't get a refresh
token in this case.
If you could get one, where
would you store it?
There's nowhere to store it.
There's no way to be secret.
So we don't have available
offline access.
One addition that we do have,
one extra feature here, is
that we allow your application
to decide whether or not the
user will be prompted.
So in some cases, of
course, the user
will have to be prompted.
They've never granted access.
But once they have grant access,
if your token's about
to expire, which it will after
60 minutes, You can just run
the flow again, but this
time passing auto.
And if you pass auto for the
approval prompt, it's clever
enough to know whether or not
the user should be prompted.
So this sounds kind of
a bit complicated.
And to be honest, writing it
yourself is not exactly
straightforward, which is why
the easiest way of doing this
is using the Google client
library that actually handled
all of this for you.
So you make a single call, and
you have a token, and you can
use that token really for as
long as the session lasts by
using it auto.
And the user will only be asked
for their access once.
Now, to show you how that
happens, Nicolas is going to
go through some samples on
the OAuth Playground.
Now, the OAuth Playground,
because it's specifically a
tool to allow you to debug and
experiment with OAuth2, we
allow you to do these various
kinds of flow.
And perhaps you might want to
experiment with them yourself
to decide which one is for you
and which one is for your
application.
Certainly, if you don't have a
heavy set server-side, making
a call to an API in JavaScript
is one of the most simple
things you can do without having
to add additional code.
So if you can get away with
this, if you get away with the
client side flow and making
client side requests, then the
JavaScript client-side
flow is for you.
Any questions?
Nicolas, Sergio, anything
to add to that?
NICOLAS GARNIER: No.
I just wanted to add also that
when you use a refresh token
to get the new access token for
service side flow, that's
called refreshing your token.
But our client libraries
usually handle that
automatically.
So our client library for Java,
for PHP, et cetera, for
Ruby, you just pass in your
refresh token and your access
token, and it's always going
to refresh the token behind
the scenes without you
even noticing it.
So you don't really need to
care about this or need to
handle this.
Just passing the refresh token,
automatically the
client library is going to use
it to get new access tokens
once your credentials
have expired.
SERGIO GOMES: Sorry, just to
add to that, I just want to
say that we actually have
different client libraries for
different languages.
And each one actually handles
things the correct way that
you would expect things to
be handled natively.
So, for example, the Java client
library allows you to
use JDO to store your
credentials and automatically
access them and refresh them and
rewrite them once they're
accessed and all that.
The iPhone one uses
native storage.
The Ruby one has different
options as well.
So they all handle this pretty
much as you would expect in
the specific language.
And they all have documentation
so that you can
take a look at how to take
advantage of these features.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Now I'm just
going to show you how things
work in details, looking at
the protocol using the
Playground.
So let me just share
my screen here.
All right, everybody sees
the Playground?
Yeah?
I guess so.
So this is the OAuth2
Playground.
You can access it going
to developers@googl
e.com/oauthplaygrounds.
And as Ali mentions, it allows
you to use some of our APIs
with OAuth2 and experiment
and see how the
protocol exactly works.
So, for instance, I'm going to
use the Google Contacts API.
That's going to be the first
example I'm going to show you.
So the tool is actually
pretty configurable.
You can use the server-side
or client-side flow here.
You can even use it with
other APIs at Google.
Just go to Custom,
and you have to
specify a bunch of things.
But there is a bunch of APIs
that also work with OAuth2
that are compatible
with it, too.
So I invite you to try it out.
So let's go.
So Contacts here.
The first step is to actually
redirect the user
to the Grant screen.
So you do that on the tool
clicking on Authorize APIs.
And as I'm already signed in,
I'm directly prompted that the
tool wants to access
my Contacts data.
So I'm going to allow
it access.
On the right side of the
tool here, we show
exactly what happened.
So the step that we've seen here
is redirecting the user
to the Grant screen.
And that's done by simply
redirecting it to this URL
that you need to construct.
And you can see a bunch of
the parameters here.
Access IP equal offline We've
talked about that.
The scope here, the scope is the
Google Contacts scope we
can see later on.
I'll add a few more APIs to see
when you add more scopes
what it does.
Approval prompt equals force.
That's a URL parameter that
what it does is that the
prompt that the users have seen
is always going to swap.
You can also remove that
URL parameter.
And the prompt is actually
only going to show up the
first time the user
approves the URL.
I'm going to remove it in a
second so you can see that the
second time I want to authorize
the API, I'll get
redirected automatically.
The user will not be prompted
to authorize.
So as you can see here,
we've been redirected
and passed a code.
The code is the first step
of the server side flow.
You have it, and you need to
exchange it against an access
token and a refresh token.
So you can see the tool
copy/pasted here automatically
in the input here.
It's pretty nice.
And how you initiate the
exchange, you simply click
that button.
And as you can see, we've
got a refresh token
and an access token.
So let's go back and see how
that worked exactly.
So to exchange the code for a
refresh token and an access
token, what you do is you send
an HTTP request, a post-HTTP
request to basically
https.accounts.g
oogle.com/O/OAuth2/token.
If you're fluent in the HTML
protocol, that's the request
on top, and below is the
response we got from the API.
But basically, you construct
the URL using the post
and the host here.
And what we've done is
we've passed inside
the body of the request.
We've passed the code, the
redirect URI which we've used
in the first step, our client ID
that we've gotten the APIs
console that Sergio has shown
you earlier, and the client
secret as well here.
It's hidden because it's the
OAuth2s Playground ones, and
we don't want to really
disclose it.
But it would be your own client
ID and your own client
secret when you use OAuth2 and
grant type authorization code
because we're passing an
authorization code, and we
want an access token and
a refresh token.
The response is a 200 OK
response that contains a
little JavaScript object here--
sorry, JSON object
which, as you can see, contains
a refresh token and
an access token.
And also, expires is the time
to leave in seconds for the
access token.
So the access token will
not be valid in
basically one hour.
And as you can see here, we
have a little countdown to
show you when exactly
that finishes.
You can refresh the access token
using the refresh token.
You can click the button.
The tool will show you how
to refresh access tokens.
So again, it's a very similar
request where you press the
client secrets, and the client
ID, and the refresh token.
And the grant type is
not code this time.
It's refresh token.
And the tool gives you back a
new access token that's valid
in another one hour.
So when your first access token
is expired, you just get
new ones like this.
Now, let's go to the third step
of how to use OAuth2.
It's basically when we use the
token to access the API.
And there are a few methods
to basically
authorize your requests.
So Google APIs, they are
mostly REST based.
So we sent a GET request to a
URL endpoint to basically list
the contacts if it's a contacts
API, or get contacts,
or post requests if you want to
insert new contacts or put
if you want to modify one.
What I'm going to show you is
we have a little something
really convenient.
It's a tool where I'm going to
show you all of the endpoints
of the API for you.
You don't have to go through
the Docs and
find the correct URL.
And if you want to list all the
contacts a user has, you
need to send a GET request
to that URL here.
I hope you see it, and the
screen isn't too small.
And you need a special mandatory
HTTP header,
gd.version, just reading the
version of the API, because we
have previous versions that
work a little differently.
And that just tells you during
the request which version you
want to use.
Here we want to use the latest,
which is Version 3.
So I'm just going
to click on it.
It's going to set
up my request.
So we want to sent a GET
request to that URL.
So when we click Send Request
here, boom, we've sent a GET
to the URL we've described
on the left.
We have the extra header
here, gd.version.
And the important part
is that's how you
authorize to our APIs.
You pass an authorization
header.
Then there's a few ways
to actually write that
authorization header.
Here we've used authorization
column OAuth.
That's from the other
protocol.
The OAuth2 protocol was
for a long time being
written, being discussed.
And in the earlier version of
the protocol, we used OAuth as
a prefix here, and then you
passed the access token.
In the newer version, you use
Bearer, so the tool actually
supports all that.
You can go and change from OAuth
prefix to Bearer prefix.
Just to show you that it works
exactly the same here, that's
the new authorization
header with Bearer.
And there's a third way to
authorize this to use a URL
parameter instead, which is
actually quite convenience, is
to use the access token
URL parameter.
And here if you want to
authorize, boom, you added--
here, we've simply added
the access token.
Instead of setting it in a
header, in an HTTP header,
we've simply appended it to the
URL with the question mark
access token equal and
the access token.
That's exactly the access token
that we've got in back
from the second step here.
And you can see below it's quite
hard to read because
it's XML data back
from the API.
But we've got all my contacts
that are available in my
Google Contacts list.
So that was a little showcase
of the server side OAuth2
flow, which contains basically
three steps--
redirecting the user to
the Authorize page.
The second step is exchanging
the code for a token.
And then the third step is
simply use the API using the
access token.
Now I'm going to show you how
to use the tool with the
client-side flow and how the
client-side flow works.
So I simply click here.
You see there's one less step,
only step one and step two.
And if I want to authorize
contacts again,
then I click Authorize.
It's going to be the same exact
page except you cannot
request for offline access.
So there is not the little
message that tells you that
the tool or that the application
is going to access
your contacts in the background
for a long time.
So you don't get that message
because the client-side flow
doesn't give you a
refresh token.
So you don't really
have offline
back end server access.
And we've got everything
back to the tools.
So as you can see here--
let me go back.
We've got in the URL in the hash
fragments directing the
access token.
So that's why there's a one
less step, basically.
You've already got
direct access.
There's no need to exchange your
code for an access or a
refresh token.
It's very simple.
You get the access token, and
you can use it directly to
send your request, for example,
to the Google
Contacts API.
One less step, very,
very simple.
The only main difference
that you will not get--
refresh token--
which allows you to get
unlimited access in a limited
period of time.
So, actually, if you need to
access the API for more than
one hour, there's some
techniques that you can use on
your web page if you're on a
JavaScript-enabled web page
and you're using this flow
to get an access token.
Some of the common techniques
are to use like a hidden
iFrame to trigger a flow inside
and get a new access
token, or trigger a pop-up
instead of redirecting the
user back and forth to your
websites, trigger a pop-up
that if the user has already
granted you access, it should
directly give you a access
token that's again
valid for one hour.
Of course, you can only use that
while the user is on your
web page, which is the main
difference between the
client-side flow and the
service-side flow, basically.
Guys, is there anything
else you'd like me to
demo or talk about?
ALI AFSHAR: Is there any way we
can have question, people
could ask questions
People have been
sitting patiently waiting.
Thank you all for listening.
Do any of you have anything
you'd like to ask?
If not, I can think
of some questions.
NICOLAS GARNIER: We can actually
demo the Playground
with Google Drive.
This GDL was supposed
to be a bit of a
Google Drive and AdSense.
I'm going to show you
a little bit how it
works with Google Drive.
We're going to go back to the
server-side flow here.
So Google Drive is this online
or in the cloud hardware that
we launched a couple
months ago.
It has a really cool API, a
really cool SDK, actually.
You can Do a lot.
The really, really basic way to
use Google Drive is to use
the API here with this scope.
This scope is--
I'm going to highlight
it here.
When the API comes, it
shows [INAUDIBLE].
I'm simply going to show you
how it works with the
Playground.
You request access.
You get the prompt.
Again, you get an authorization
code, which I'm
going to exchange.
Below is the older refresh and
access token from before.
I'm going to exchange that
authorization code for a new
refresh and access token,
which I've gotten.
And now if I want to use the
API here, I have a bunch of
endpoints, lots of things
you can do with the API.
The most common one would
probably be to list files.
I just have to find
it somewhere.
List parents?
No, list files here.
So if you want to list all the
files that you have in your
drive, you're simply going to
send a GET request to that
request URI.
Here, I'm going to remove
the gd.editor.
Let's try it out.
It could be quite big.
So here, I have a bunch
of files in my drive.
That's my drive, here as you
can see, a bunch of images
everything.
Let me go back to
the Playground.
And as you can see here, for
example, so the newer--
our older APIs in Google
used to be XML based.
And our newer account of APIs
or now all the new APIs are
mostly JSON-based, which is
when you're getting here a
JSON response.
So you can see in the items
you have all my files.
For example, this is my
first file title.
That's my accounting
spreadsheet, which has a
special [INAUDIBLE] because
it's a Google spreadsheet.
You can see if it's starred.
Yes, it's starred.
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
And then you can use the API
to, for example, insert new
files to Google Drive or modify
your files, modify file
sharing, et cetera.
There's also a really cool
feature of the Google Drive
SDK, is that you can have your
applications integrate
directly inside Google Drive.
So, for example, here if you
look at the PNG here, that's
an image file, a driver.
You can open it with-- it will
now let you open it with
third-party applications.
And actually, the OAuth2
Playground is one of these
applications.
So if you want to have the
OAuth2 Playground listed here
to open your files in Google
Drive, you can simply go to
the Chrome Web Store to the
Google Drive Apps collection,
which is here on left,
Google Drive.
And you'll find that's all the
apps that are Google Drive
enabled that you can install on
your drive, which have the
right-click open-with
functionality.
The OAuth2 Playground is one
of them, and you simply
install it.
And then you'll be able to do
this, which is right-click,
open with the OAuth2 Playground
on any files.
We go through it, and that
describes how it works if
you're developing Google
Drive apps.
So if you're developing Google
Drive apps and the user clicks
on the file inside Google Drive,
it will redirect him to
your website with special
URL parameters
that you can see here.
It will give you a code right
away, a code that's the OAuth2
protocol that needs two
central tokens.
But we also give you here a JSON
object in the state URL
parameter, which contains the
ID of the file that the user
just opened and the action
that happened.
The user opened the file.
Here is the ID.
And you now have access using
the authorization code.
So here, if I exchange the code,
I'm getting a refresh
token and an access token.
And here are the tools.
It's nice.
It gives you right away the
URL to the file to get the
details of the file.
So here is how Drive works.
You get the details
of the file.
Here it's drivegoogle.png.
It's a PNG image.
It is not stored or anything.
You have all the created
and modified dates.
So that's the metadata
of the files.
And if you want to download the
actual content, here you
have a download URL, which you
can request, sending an
authorized request with OAuth2
actually as well, and you get
the actual content.
So here, if I do an authorized
request to that URL, you see
I'm getting PNG binary data.
That's my file here, actually.
SERGIO GOMES: So just before we
run out of time, I'd just
like to do a quick AdSense
demo as well with another
tool, which will be very useful
to you no matter what
API you're developing
in, which is
the Google APIs Explorer.
And I've got it opened up here
to show you the methods in the
AdSense Management API.
Now, you can get a list.
This uses the same data that
is used to generate our
documentation, by the way.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And
just a quick note.
SERGIO GOMES: Yep.
NICOLAS GARNIER: I wanted to
state the main difference
between the APIs Explorer and
the OAuth2 Playground.
So the OAuth Playground really
explains to you how the
protocol works step by step,
and then you can use it to
access APIs, Google APIs.
The APIs for here, it's going
to hide the OAuth2 protocol
that happens, all the
OAuth2 stuff.
And it just lets you play
around with the APIs.
SERGIO GOMES: Exactly.
And it's going to be very useful
for you to figure out
how to make a request.
So in this case, for example, I
first just want to list all
of the ad clients in
my AdSense account.
So I find the method here.
I click it.
And you see that it
automatically gives you a
little form with all
of the parameters
that the method expects.
Now, since this is an authorized
request, you're
going to have go through the
OAuth flow as well here.
And the tool has this
convenient little
thing set up here.
You can choose which scopes
you want to get access to.
Since I only want to read data,
I'm just going to choose
the AdSense read-only scope,
and I authorize it.
It gives me a pop-up, which you
probably didn't see due to
the way that that screensharing
works in this.
But now I should be able
to make my request.
And if I click the Execute
button here, sure enough, I
get all of the ad
clients listed.
And the same thing works for
other methods like the most
important and most used method
in the Management API, the
method which allows you
to generate reports.
As you can see here, it shows
you all the different fields
that you can fill in, all of the
mandatory ones, which are
highlighted in red, and all
of the optional ones.
And you can just fill these
in, click Execute, and see
what happens.
If I click here, it just
tells me these
parameters are required.
But if I were to fill them in
with the date, let's say
2001-01-01 and 2012-01-01, and
then just add a couple of
dimensions and metrics, like for
example, reporting based
on month, and just adding
another metric, which would
be, for example, earnings, this
would allow me to get a
report for all of my
AdSense earnings
between those two dates.
And here you go.
You just get you a list of rows,
and they've all got the
information you need.
So you can just take this
JSON, put it into your
application, and build some
graphs with it, or some other
visualization.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Nice.
So Ali needed to go.
And we have a question from
Gary Frederick here on the
chat, on the group
chat on the left.
He wanted to know how you can
use OAuth2 on Android.
So actually OAuth2 on
Android, there's two
main ways to use it.
One of the ways would
be to actually use--
and that's what people are doing
in iOS, mostly, is to
use an embedded web view.
So you basically de-app your app
if it's a native Android
app or a native iOS app to
trigger a web view and start
the OAuth2 flow inside
web view.
And you would get
the code back.
So we're going to use the
server-side flow for this.
You're going to read the code
from the URL once the user has
approved your flow.
And then use the code inside
your app to do the exchange of
the code for tokens,
et cetera.
And then once you have the
access token, the refresh
token, you save that, and you
can use it in the background
to access the APIs.
In Android, there's another
way to do that, only in
Android, not in iOS, which is
the preferred way, actually,
which is what the Android
team wants us to do.
And so it's to use the
account manager.
So I don't have--
I can't show you the
code right now.
It's actually a bit long.
But it's available.
And you can find samples
of that in--
I think the Tasks API documents
should have that, or
we can also find it, of
course, in the Android
documentation somewhere.
No, so the account manager does
not have refresh tokens.
What it does is it's going to
handle the refreshing for you.
So what you do is you use the
account manager to request
access to the user's data.
And the account manager has
a special UI for approval.
And what is good is that it
uses the accounts that are
already signed it or already
set up in your device.
So it's going to pop-up a nice
little window, a native
window, asking, well, this
application wants to use kind
of like all the authorizations
you have in Android.
If you want to access the
internet or the calendar data,
there's a way where you
can set it up to
access OAuth2 APIs.
So in the code, when you specify
the type of data that
we want to access, you use, I
think, something like OAuth2
column, and then
add the scopes.
And then So the UI's going to
show you, OK, well, this
application wants to access, for
example, the Contacts data
and also the Google Drive
data, et cetera.
And if the user approves, the
intent is actually going to
provide you with an access
token directly.
So it's not going to give
you a refresh token.
It's always going to give
you access token.
So what your app can do is go
through this flow again
subsequent times when the access
token has expired.
And the same thing here.
The user is not going to be
prompted subsequent times.
Since the user has already
approved, next time you
request it, the intent is
already automatically going to
give you the access token.
So that's kind of how
the refresh is done.
So to use the account manager,
set the OAuth2 scopes, and
give it the OAuth2 scopes
you want to access.
And then you'll have a nice
native flow that directly
gives you the access tokens.
SERGIO GOMES: I just want to
add something to that.
If you're going to be doing
development in Android and
accessing Google APIs, you
should definitely take a look
at the Java client library for
Google APIs, because it
handles a lot of this stuff for
you behind the scenes so
you don't have to touch any
of this complicated stuff.
And it had some very good sample
code on how you can do
authorizations in Android.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So Gary's
comment here-- "The Java
client library was not
as clear." It's true.
It's true.
Because it's mostly targeted
as full web apps right now,
though I think there is extra
packages, they have the Javas
have a suffix like Android or
Android2 or that kind of
stuff, which you can use, which
gives you a bunch of
helpers to do this.
But the best is to
find a sample.
And I think there is a specific
Android sample in the
Java client library samples.
You need to specifically
look for it.
If you look at the other
Java samples, of
course, it's web apps.
And you really need to
look at that sample.
I actually built a sample
that was using the
Tasks API using OAuth2.
It was about a year ago, which
is slightly outdated.
You can find it online.
It's very easy.
Type Tasks API, Android
sample, or something.
But it's slightly outdated
because the Android SDK has
evolved since then.
SERGIO GOMES: I just want to
point out that they've
actually been making a lot of
improvements to this in the
Java client library.
So I'm not sure how long ago it
was that you took a look at
this, but it made some
recent improvements.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Look
really inside--
actually, try not to look too
much at my Google task sample,
because it's really outdated.
Really go inside the Google APIs
client library samples on
Google project hosting, and
that's where you'll find
usually up-to-date
samples for this.
And then, yes, you'll have to
use the Google APIs client
library for which you can
add a helper class.
I think there must be one for
cloud storage since it's what
server you want to use.
And then use the Cloud Storage
specific binaries that we
published with it, which should
give you easy access to
all the Cloud Storage stuff.
But I'm not super familiar
with Cloud Storage drive.
I could help you better.
I think that Cloud Storage,
however, is not going to use
the user's credential.
Cloud Storage is more for
users that work with
credentials.
So you have to use your own
credentials to access the
Cloud Storage, which might be
a little bit different, a
little bit tricky.
SERGIO GOMES: Nicolas, I think
we're going to talk to the
Android team and try to convince
them have an OAuth
session of their own, because
it might help a lot
of folks out there.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And definitely,
because, yes.
And Gary, because we're out of
time, so we have to leave the
chat very soon, but feel free
to go on Stack Overflow.
Post your questions.
We're always go on Stack
Overflow a couple hours a day
and try to answer questions.
Ask your questions there.
Use the correct tags.
We'll find it.
And we'll help you out from
there and give you specific
information just for you,
for your use case.
All right.
Thanks, Heather.
Thanks, Gary.
SERGIO GOMES: We might have
time for one more question
before we have to go.
So if anyone has any questions
on the web server flows client
side or server side, ask now.
We give you 10 seconds.
You can put in on the group chat
if you're too shy to talk
up, to speak up.
They're all muted.
Maybe there is--
that's because it's a
Hangout on there.
SERGIO GOMES: Right, exactly.
NICOLAS GARNIER: You
guys are not shy.
SERGIO GOMES: You're just going
to have to use the chat
if you have questions for us.
Sorry about that.
All right, if there is no
questions, guys, then we'll
see what Gary is typing.
SERGIO GOMES: Why is it--
NICOLAS GARNIER: "What was so
hard?" Well, let me tell you.
It's much easier than OAuth1.
SERGIO GOMES: Oh, yeah,
that's for sure.
If you had to deal with OAuth1,
you wouldn't be asking
that question.
NICOLAS GARNIER: But definitely
use our client libraries.
If you just understand the
flow, all the protocol is
heading for you.
You just have to know what the
authorization page is, what
refresh is.
Actually, refresh is
mostly hidden.
So this makes it way,
way, way simpler.
And look at the code sample.
Usually, most of the stuff is
really, really hidden by our
client libraries, the
protocol itself.
Yes, definitely.
So the thing is OAuth2,
it was really like--
SERGIO GOMES: [INAUDIBLE]
question of watching the
video, like they
won't able to know.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Oh, yeah, we
have to read the questions.
You're right.
OAuth2, some of the
documentation is still needing
updating but getting
updated everyday.
Yeah, so the OAuth2
spec was under--
still in the draft and still a
draft, though I'd heard that
the spec has just been frozen.
So it's soon going to be like
a real spec, a final spec.
And then we can spend more
time updating the doc,
publishing nice stuff around
that, help with tools now that
we know the spec won't change.
Because right now, if you look
at other OAuth2 providers,
like Facebook or that uses
OAuth2, it's actually quite
different from the way Google
uses the OAuth2.
It's simply that we haven't
implemented
OAuth2 at the same time.
Google is always updating it to
meet the latest standard.
But Facebook is probably using
an older standard and updating
it as well.
And it's currently
a moving target.
It has just been frozen.
So it's finally going to
be a little nicer.
Things hopefully are going to
start being cross compatible.
We'll see.
Can I ask another question from
Gary? "Can I have a token
that works for Android
and Chrome Web Apps?
Does that make sense?"
Yes, so the token that you get
from Android, the access
token, you use it on your Chrome
Web App, though you're
not going to get a refresh
token from Android.
So it's always going to be
access tokens, which are only
valid one hour, which you could,
if you wanted, to have
a protocol to send it from
your Android app, to your
Chrome back end, to your
Chrome Web App
back end if you wanted.
Maybe it's better to do it the
other way, get a refresh token
and an access token from your
Chrome Web App, and have some
mutual pull back between
the two.
So from Android, you get
tokens from you Chrome
Web App back end.
And, of course, you can use the
access tokens from Android
or from Chrome from
the web app.
They all work the same way.
So you'll definitely be able to
do that if you find how to
fix or work around the
trickiness around Android that
doesn't give you a
refresh token.
SERGIO GOMES: I just want to
point out that you can have as
many projects as you want.
So if these are two different
applications, you should
probably get two different sets
of developer credentials
for both of them and try to get
your users to authorize
both of them.
Yeah, right.
OK, so I see you're on the chat,
and you're commenting
that it's the same
application.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICOLAS GARNIER: You probably
don't want the users to have
to authorize twice.
SERGIO GOMES: Right.
NICOLAS GARNIER: You want the
user to think, oh, I'm already
authorized on the web app, and
I don't want to authorize
again on the Android app.
That seems weird.
I've already authorized.
So probably the best way, if
you do it from Android the
first time, is to go through
a web flow--
sorry, an animated web view and
get the refresh token and
the access token, and save it
in your common database, and
use that common database
for both apps.
And same thing if your
coming from the
Chrome Web App, I guess.
That's probably the
best way for you.
It's little bit tricky to
do it from Android.
And we don't have helpers to
really help you do OAuth2 from
a web view, though, because we
are trying to push more for
the account manager
in this case.
SERGIO GOMES: Right.
But then he'll have to also go
through the web app every time
that he needs to generate
a new access token.
So it needs to be the web app
generating your access token
from the refresh token.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Or you could
have the refresh token saved
into your Android database.
But the real trickiness is
that you need to use your
client ID and your
client secrets to
use the refresh token.
And that's usually something
you really, really want to
keep secret and you don't want
people to take your APK, and
reverse engineering, and
de-obfuscate it, and be able
to read your client ID and your
client secrets, and use
that to hack and take your quota
and that kind of stuff.
So you'll probably need to
have secret communication
between your Android app and
your back end that's holding
the refresh and the
access token.
To talk more, definitely right
now Stack Overflow
is your best bet.
We can really have a
conversation on Stack
Overflow, start a forum.
You can probably find me on
Stack Overflow as well--
Nicolas Garnier.
I think there's a way in Stack
Overflow to add me with a + or
an @ Nicolas Garnier, and
all those kind of
things, so I get notified.
Or I'm also on Google+.
If you post a question there
or an open discussion or an
open forum, ping me the link
on Google+, on my profile.
And I'll get on it, and we can
chat there. stack Overflow is
great because everybody can
see the discussion.
And if it contains a
valuable resource,
everybody will see it.
So that's what we
like about it.
It's more scalable.
SERGIO GOMES: All right.
We're already almost 10 minutes
into overtime, so I
think we're going to have
to end this one here.
NICOLAS GARNIER: OK, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for the questions.
And thanks for listening
all the way.
And Gary, you know, please
follow up on Stack Overflow.
I'll be happy to
help you there.
So yeah, we hope you liked it.
SERGIO GOMES: All right.
Bye, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Bye-bye.